[音楽]
なきゃいいって皆さん聞いたことありますか
をないあのやっぱりおじさま方にパラ蹴りっていうとパナパナ
ジュリアナ東京っていうふうに入れることがすごい多いんですけどもそのパラではあり
ません
腹キャリイと1されるキャリアますなぁ地複数の仕事を同時に実践する働き方のことを
いいます
いませんそが取り組んでいる働き方改革の一つにも副業や兼業などのパールキャリア
含まれています
かく言う私もですね
先ほど紹介なりました通り自分の会社
大学時代に作ったハピキラ factory て自分の会社をやりながら
署員という会社でも働くパラキャリイ女子です
今日はそんなパラキャリイという新しい働き方生き方についてお話をしたいと思います
思い返してみると小さい時から私は一つのことに集中するのがあまり得意な子どもでは
ありませんでした
バイオリンにバレエをことにスイミング
常に ok ok 高は複数やってみました
そんな一つのことに集中するのが苦手な私が生まれて初めて
長い時間向き合うことができたもの
それが長野県の小布施という場所でした
人口はおよそ1万人なので最も小さな町です
そんなお店に25年間東京でしか暮らしたことがない私が初めていって思ったこと
正直見ます
うわぁ
何も苗
カフェもないクラブもないなんなら歩いていける距離にコンビニもないんですよ
正直衝撃の場所でした
でもいいにでも衝撃を受けました
それは並感
オブジェに住んでいる人たちが小布施のことが大好きでお布施に住んでいることを誇り
に思っていたことです
東京に暮らしていると東京に住んでいる自分のことを誇りに思うなんてことは全く
なかったので彼らのことが少し羨ましく思いました
と同時にこれまで自分が抱いてきた
成功とか幸せの価値観に疑問を持たんです
私は小さい時からまあ新学校に通っていたこともあっていい大学に入っていい会社に
入っていいクルマに乗って
っていうことを人生の成功として教えられてきました
でも
小布施の人たちは全くそんな意識を持っていなかったん
でも彼らはすごく幸せそうだったんです
そんな彼らを見て思ったのは
これまでのように東京にある物質的な豊かさ以上に
これからは小布施にあるような精神的な豊かさというのが大事にされるようなそんな
時代が来るのではないか
そんなことを思いました
だったら東京で世界でバリバリエリートサラリーマンとしてやっている人たちがあっ
小布施のような地方に憧れ基本追い求める時代が確実に来ると
そう思った私が作ったのが
この地方をテーマでした博士はファクトリーという会社です
ハッピーファクトリーは今年の9月で丸5年を迎えます
ハピキラ factory を作った年の冬私は当時大学3年生だったので就職発動の
時期を迎えました
就職するべきかしないべきかん
すっごく迷ったんですけども結局就職こうしてみることにしました
ん
その理由
ミレニアル世代の価値観であります
ミレニアル世代た私のように2000年代方に成人した若者世代時のことを言うんです
けれどもこの世代の価値観の特徴の一つはバランス x 字型であることが特徴です
仕事も趣味も家族も友達も
そして恋愛結婚も
ぶっちゃけそれぞれは70点ぐらいでもいいから人生全体としてバランスをこなして
いく
このから離していくよことによって120点と言いたいと
そういうふうに考えたんです
なので今こう社会で活躍している大人たちに比べると圧倒的に仕事に割ける時間は
少ないと思いました
じゃあその時に仕事に割ける時間が少ない分お金が少なくていいのかな
稼げるお金が少なくていいのかなと考えました
さをどうやって自分の高生活パターンを考えてみると私
校長頼む時ってロイヤルミルクティー頼んじゃうしハンバーガー頼む時もなんか
アボカドトッピング300円ですよ
チェダーチーズトッピング200ペルミ戦ながらトッピング代の方開4ぐらいの
そういうた飲み方をしてしまうタイプなんですね
なので人よりもお金が必要だと単純に思いました
ああああああ
悪い
左も短い時間で人にもたくさん稼がなきゃいけなかったんです私
どういうことかというと自分の1時間当たりの価値っていうのを最大化しない限り私は
自分のもう人生を描くことができないと
どうしたら自分の1時間当たりの価値最大化できるのか
そう考えたときに3つの方法があると思いました
まず1つ目
ナンバーワン戦略
世の中で何が一番になれば自分の1時間当たりの価値は最大ができる
無理だと思いましたん
だって学校のテストですが一番堪えなかったし部活でも一番と言えなかったのに
そんな私は世の中で一番どれなんでもありえないと
諦めました
次ファースター戦略
これはまぁちょっと冷静に考えてみたんですけど人類の歴史はこれだけ長いと電気も
あるしバスもあるし水道も鉄道もあるしなぁこういうテレックスみたいな素晴らしい
イベントが出てきちゃってるし
世の中にないものを作り出すってめっちゃむずいちゃんと思っ
でこれも諦めました
残されたのがオンリーワン戦略だったんですよね
じゃあどうしたら自分がオンリーワンの存在になれるのか
当時私は女子大生社長でした卒業したら元女子大生社長でした
女子ない戦車ちゃってオンリーワンなのって自分で自分に聞いたんですよ
そしたのイオン電話じゃないよねっと思ったんですというのもう当時私たちの世代で
すごく学生企業が流行った世代だったので
女子大生社長ってもう朝かいたんでしょ
でしかもそんな私たちを見て女子高生たちが高校生今日いるけどね
女子高生たちが私たちもやるとなる女子高生社長とか言い始めるわけですよ
女子大生社長立場ない理由
で a
じゃあどういう風にしたら自分の価値が一番幸高まるのかなったことを考えたときに
うんちゃらかんちゃらなんちゃらなのに社長っていう文脈に自分のことを置いてみたら
どうかと
つまるところはもう超単純な話なんですけど1/100の存在理由で1/100の存在
にしたが1万分の1の存在がれるよねみたいな
そういう考え方せこういう働き方に自分のことを置いてみようとなので一度光
会社に入って自分の会社も
続けるってことしてみようと思ったんですね
こうして私のから借り人生は始まりました
ちなみに
皆さんご存知だと思うんですけどもしドラで有名なとラッ
もうこのパラ仮については長者と結びつけて論じています
全然関係ないことじゃんと思うと思うんですけどどういうことかっていうとこれまで
っていうのは組織の自分に比べて個人の地面をすごく短かったので
で個人は一つの組織に所属して働いていれば安心
に安全楽しく働けたんですね
ところがどっこい
個人の寿命が延びました
そうすると一つ目の会社に入っていてもその会社潰れちゃうんですよ
だからその会社が潰れる前に第3の人生第三の人生の準備をしておかないとやばいと
だからパターンなんだぜっていうふうにドラッカーを言ってるんですそれ聞いてもそう
そう私もそう思うと思って
なのでそういうドラッカーが言ってることを実践していくのは私たちみたいなミレニア
次第なのかなというふうに思っています
ん
まあそんな感じだったらあの始まった私のパラたり人生なんですけれども
実際どういう働き方してんのって聞かれることがすごい多いので今日はちょっとまとめ
てきました
普段の生活では平日の昼間にソニーの仕事をし平日の朝や夕方
あとはまあ土日の好きな時にですね自分の歯匹がの仕事をしているという感じです
こちら見ていただくとあるんですけども寒いの柴田しながら
まあ友達で夜は飲んだり会社の人と飲んでいい
あとはまあカフェでお茶飲んだりいってもいつも飲んでるみたいになっちゃうんです
けど
まあ飲んで楽しくやってますではそんな楽しい働き方自分じゃ出来てるなぁと思い
ながらもう
やっぱり新しい働き方なので
今も模索中の課題3つあります
まず1つ目
やっぱり時間のバランスとんぼがめちゃくちゃ難しいんですよ
ソニーの仕事楽しい発表の仕事楽しい
そうするとついてそればっかやりがちなんですね
である日突然おばあちゃんが部悪くなったんですうちの
でその時に思ったんです
このままおばあちゃんが死んじゃったら私は公開しないのかと
後悔すると思いましたこんな仕事ばっかりせた
だからそこから意識的にまずじゃあ家族にはこれだけ時間を割こうとか
友達にはこれだけ時間を作ろうとかじゃあ趣味はこれだけ時間必要だよねという形で
人生配分表というものを作り始めました
何かっていうと自分の人生をどういうふうに配分するかってだけなんですけど
まあそれこそハピキラソニーか作ってもいろんな項目を並べてそれぞれに対してどれ
ぐらいの時間を使いたいあってことを自分で決めるんですね最初に
でそれを google カレンダーにこういう風な形で色分けして落としていって
えっそれをまあ日々管理していくと
で今のマーコ割合としてはソニー3割ハピキラ3割
すまたん4割っていう風な感じになってるんですけどもよく突っ込まれるのがこのその
他4割に含まれる
紫色
オスシート雨書いてありますけどこれ何だと思いますか
その通りこれ彼氏との時間です
彼氏との時間は1週間に7%で決めてます
ええええええ
ポイントはところはもっと書いてるようだけど物理的には7%って言ってるじゃん
さあ
ブーバー線と鉄筋へ日あるいい感じ運用がすごく大事ですそんな感じで管理してます
そして2つ目
やっぱり時間が短くなってしまうので限られた時間でどうやってゴールに近づくかって
ことはすごく課題です
仕事できない分仕事の時間が短い分成果が出ないんじゃないのっていうふうに突っ込ま
れることも多いんですけれども
これについては私の人生のモットーでもある
ローコストでハイパーハッピーっていうの原則にしてますってどういうことかって言う
とすごい頑張んなきゃいけない事はやらなくてすごい版もなくても結果が出やすいこと
だけあります
話なんですけどなので好きなこと得意なことは一生懸命やります
苦手なことは好きなことのほうで稼いだお金を使って人様にお仕事としてお願いをし
ますというふうな形にしてます例えば私こんなこと言ったら絶対怒られるんですけど
選択がめちゃくちゃ嫌いでもう濡れた t シャツとか触れないんですよ
でありません
家にいませんたくありません
私は妹選択大根サービスというものを使ってねこれ好きな柔軟剤の匂いとか選べて段位
がいいとか言うとダウンにで洗って持ってきてくれるんですよ
このサービスを使うことによって1週間たビューいた1時間2時間3時間という時間を
自分の好きなあるいは得意なソニーと赤ピアノ時間なっていく
そういった形で自分の1時間あたりにできること成果を出しやすい働き方っていうのを
自分で模索しています
そして最後に3つ目
これは一番大変なんですよ周囲の理解
お前なんでそんな働き方してんのっても普通に言うんですよね先輩だてはね
ででもなんかこういろんな人の話を聞いたときに私気づいたことがあってねー
今大人たちがこの働き方について
切れてくるのって別に怒ってるから切れてるわけじゃないんですよ
えっそういう働き方ってありなの俺知らなかったんだけど俺さらにもう1本なんだけど
まじふざけんなってなるの
ずっと pro
びっくりしちゃってるだけなんですよ
須磨びっくりっていう感情がなぜか怒りとか綺麗に出ちゃうんですよねえええ
ピザに気づいてからはあ
怒られたと思うでしょんぼりするよりもちゃんとどうして自分はこれ働くとしてんのか
とかどういう考え方でこういうことしてるのかってことを説明する
銀のが私にあるんだなっていうふうに思ってなのでなんでだよっていう風に言われたら
その理由をきちんと答えるようにしています
まあそういう形でまあいろいろとこう課題はありながらもうこのパラ会という働き方
これからプルんじゃないかなというふうに思っていて
やっぱりこう今まで行って一つの組織に所属してその諸組織のコースペイントして働く
まあ会社員とかねそういう形で働くっていうのが当たり前だったけれどもこれからは
自分の人生というのを中心にしていろんな活動とかお仕事っていうのを組み合わせて
働いていく空想いう働き方が来るんじゃないかな
っていうふうなことを思っています
まあただ
ある日突然皆さんにともそれこそ今日ですよね
みんなでパラカにしろよしろよーっていう風に言ったところでなかなか皆さんできない
と思うんですよ
だって無理じゃん
なんか怒られそうだした反対とかされそうだしさ
そうなった時にまず私が提案したいなと思っているのは
女性の腹キャリ実践です
やっぱりよの一般男性にぱな距離を進めたところでやっぱりここ
この先数年は男性てー一家の大黒柱にならざるを得ない部分もやっぱり大きいので
なかなか高リスク取りづらいと思うんですよね
一方女性は女性は
よくもあるともうキャリアが流動的だなというふうに思っていて結婚します
子供を産みますそしたら39でしょ育休でしょ
それが終わったと思ったら小山会方でしょ
色々とキャリア連続的に住むのがすごく難しい要因がやっぱり女性のが多いんですよね
その時にだからじゃあそれを逆手にとってもっとしなやかに自由にここまで多様なくて
もいいですけど
働いてみるっていうのは女性ならではの特恵なんじゃないかなというふうに私は思って
います
でそして
私はビュッフェキャリアっていうふうに読んでるんですけどもなんか方幸せのキョン
てー
好きなことを好きなバランスで好きなだけすることだと私は思うんですね
なのでホテルのビュッフェに行きました
あ今日朝バハも無事だったんですけど
カレーがありますパスタがありますデザートがあります
もしもアナタが加齢だけおいしそうと思ったら彼だけを食べ続ける人生っていうのが
好きだと思うんですだからさらにもう1本
ok 経営者1本最高ところが私の場合は単純に
アパレ美味しそうあるパスタも美味しそうみたいな
だから両方等ダメてみようでも両方ともフルフライを食べたものがいっぱいになっ
ちゃうから
7割ぐらいでのひとこみたいな
それだけの話なんですよなので副業とか金魚とか働き方改革とか言うとめちゃくちゃ
こうなんかビッパの話に聞こえると思うんですけどどっちかというとビュフェ2着て
感覚としては
ただ皆さんがこういう風な働き方はなかなか好実態とし知らないあるこそこういう風な
働き方できないんじゃないかなというふうに思って今日はこの場でお話しをさせて
いただきました
パラレルキャリアっていう働き方はすべての働く人の人生を圧倒的に幸せシュール
新たな選択肢です
もしも今日この話を聞いていいなっていうふうに思ってくださる方がいれば今日からで
も朝からでもぜひ試してみてください以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]